Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. sport sport sport it's all that we've been talking about it's all that the national media has been talking about in the aftermath of the astonishing kings and queens of england world cop and dominic we've had several i'm sure you said do you know I'm so excited and I'm so shattered from the drama of it all that I can barely remember how to say it in English You're like a trembling wreck The adrenaline has coursed through your...
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、提前解锁系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。体育，体育，体育，这就是我们一直在谈论的全部内容，这也是在经历了令人震惊的英格兰国王与女王世界杯之后，国家媒体一直在谈论的全部内容。多米尼克，我们有几个，我确信你说过，你知道吗，我太兴奋了，我被这一切的戏剧性折磨得筋疲力尽，以至于我几乎记不起怎么用英语说出来了。你就像一个颤抖的残骸，肾上腺素在你的……
I am a trembling wreck World Cup Have you kind of come to terms with the drama of it all? Have you processed it? Well, so for those people who don't know What the hell are we talking about? We ran a World Cup of Kings and Queens of England on Twitter processed it um well so for those people who don't know what the hell we're talking about yeah we ran a world cup of um kings and queens of england on twitter and 84 000 people voted or rather there
我是一个颤抖的残骸。世界杯。你是否有点接受了这一切的戏剧性？你消化它了吗？好吧，对于那些不知道的人来说，我们在谈论什么鬼东西？我们在推特上举办了一场英格兰国王与女王世界杯。消化它，嗯，好吧，对于那些不知道我们在谈论什么鬼东西的人，是的，我们在推特上举办了一场嗯英格兰国王与女王世界杯，有 84,000 人投票，或者更确切地说，
were 84 000 votes i think it's probably slightly more accurate to say and uh in the end some of us could have been voting under multiple identities yeah not that we were um but um at the end uh athelstan prevailed over elizabeth the final by the absolute tiniest margin. By the barest of margins. So 50.5%, 49.5%. And the lead changed hands several times. The game was extended overnight so people in America could vote. And Athelstan, who was unseeded, prevailed.
有 84,000 票，我想说得稍微准确一点的话，而且，最终，我们中的一些人可能是用多个身份投票的，是的，虽然我们没有这么做，嗯，但是，在最后，埃塞尔斯坦在决赛中以绝对微弱的优势战胜了伊丽莎白。以毫厘之差。所以是 50.5% 对 49.5%。领先优势几经易手。比赛延长到了夜间，这样美国的粉丝也可以投票。最终，未被列为种子选手的埃塞尔斯坦胜出了。
It was very exciting. And it's a fun way to get into the subject of talking about the kings and queens of England, which is something that i grew up you know so many people who got into history they're sort of the structure the scaffolding if you like were the stories of the kings and queens weren't they they're still the way in which actually we structure um english history the reign of so-and-so the elizabethan age tudors yeah whatever yeah so we thought it was a fun way to sort of get into this subject and what we're going to do so we have done a podcast already on the
这非常令人兴奋。这是一个切入谈论英格兰国王与女王这一主题的有趣方式，这是我从小就接触的，你知道的，很多涉足历史的人，他们的结构或脚手架，如果你愿意的话，就是国王和女王的故事，不是吗？它们仍然是我们构建英国历史的方式，某某人的统治，伊丽莎白时代，都铎王朝，等等，等等。所以我们认为这是一个有趣的切入点，我们要做的，所以我们已经制作了一期关于
winner on the unexpected winner who was athelstan and tom what we thought we'd do today was to talk about the people who got knocked out in the in the first round didn't we yes because i think i think the the value of this from the point of view of um you know of of history the academic value of this as opposed to the massive sports excitement which we in no way want to underplay um is that uh it it enables us to look at the kind of the institution of the monarchy and how it's evolved and changed and what i think also what people's reactions how they vote and so on what that says about our attitude to history to monarchy and so on but it does also enable us to provide various kind of short portraits of uh significant figures exactly in english history and i think that's what we should focus on today so the tomorrow's
胜者、那个出人意料的胜者——埃塞尔斯坦的播客了。汤姆，我们今天打算做的是聊聊那些在第一轮就被淘汰的人，对吧？是的，因为我认为，从历史的角度来看，这种学术价值，而不是我们在任何情况下都不想轻描淡写的巨大体育狂热，在于它使我们能够审视君主制这种体制，以及它是如何演变和改变的，而且我认为人们的反应、他们的投票等等，这也体现了我们对历史、君主制的态度等等。但它也确实让我们能够为英国历史上的重要人物提供各种简短的肖像，正是如此，这正是我们今天应该关注的。所以明天的
episode we'll we'll look a bit more at the kind of the institution the historiography that kind of stuff um but today we should so so there were there were we we began with... Obviously, there'd been kind of knockout rounds, but 16 had made the actual World Cup. Well, that was controversial in and of itself, wasn't it? It was. So we didn't have Alfred the Great for reasons that we have discussed in great length in our preview podcast,
节目中，我们将更多地审视这种制度、史学等等；但今天我们应该——所以有——我们开始时——显然，会有淘汰赛，但有 16 人进入了真正的世界杯。嗯，这本身就很具争议，不是吗？确实如此。所以我们没有阿尔弗雷德大帝，原因我们在预热播客中已经详细讨论过了，
because England did not exist when Alfred the Great was king. He was king of Wessex only. That was your ground for excluding him, but also because you were worried he wouldn't win. You love Alfred the Great so much. And it king of Wessex only. That was your ground for excluding him, but also because you were worried he wouldn't win. You love Alfred the Great so much. It's clear now that he probably would have won. But we did include Oliver Cromwell, Lord Protector, because
因为当阿尔弗雷德大帝在位时，英格兰并不存在。他只是威塞克斯的国王。这是你排除他的理由，但也是因为你担心他不会赢。你太喜欢阿尔弗雷德大帝了。而且——他只是威塞克斯的国王。这是你排除他的理由，但也是因为你担心他不会赢。你太喜欢阿尔弗雷德大帝了。现在很清楚，他当时很可能会赢。但我们确实纳入了护国公奥利弗·克伦威尔，因为
we said he was a bit like a king, and he filled a king-shaped hole, and also because we knew it would get people talking, which it did. So we had some absolutely outraged listeners. A man called Capel Loft, one of our, formerly a friend of the show, I think now.
我们说他有点像国王，他填补了一个国王形状的空缺，还因为我们知道这会引发讨论，果不其然。所以我们有一些绝对愤怒的听众。一个叫卡佩尔·洛夫特（Capel Loft）的人，他是我们的——以前算是节目的朋友，我想现在是
An adversary of the show. A bit more semi-detached. He mounted his own rifle World Cup. Yes, he did. With lots of kind of Hanifarians. We didn't have any of the Georges. We left out William III. We are going to do an episode later next year,
节目的对手了。关系有点疏离了。他发起了他自己的步枪世界杯。是的，他是这么做的。带着一大批哈讷法利安人（Hanifarians）。我们没有把任何乔治国王列入其中。我们漏掉了威廉三世。我们明年晚些时候会做一期节目，
just about the Georges, aren't we? Just for capital love. To show that we listen to our listeners. We're the People's Podcast, aren't we? We are the People's Podcast. I will just say one thing, which is I know that his alternative World Cup was not featured in The Times. Unlike some World Cup second mention. But if he's feeling cross and he's about to cancel us again, I will repeat, we are going to do a podcast about the hanoverians anyway let's so basically
专门讲讲乔治们，不是吗？就为了卡佩尔·洛夫特。为了证明我们倾听听众的意见。我们是人民的播客，对吧？我们是人民的播客。我只想说一件事，那就是我知道他的另类世界杯没有登上《泰晤士报》。不像某些世界杯获得了二次提及。但如果他感到生气并且准备再次取消我们，我会重复一遍，我们无论如何都会做一个关于汉诺威王朝的播客。好吧，基本上
you know we'd we're forgetting about edward ii richard ii henry vii edward viii all these duds who are out of the tournament i did like the idea that somebody suggested that we should do one on the worst kings and queens the worst kings would be hilarious so that'd be fun wouldn't it yeah that's something perhaps forward to um so we're going to crack on so the kings that we're talking about today have done very well to get to this round but they fell at the first major hurdle so we should just list the seeds so it was Elizabeth I
你知道的，我们要抛开爱德华二世、理查德二世、亨利七世、爱德华八世，所有这些在锦标赛中出局的废柴。我确实喜欢这样一个主意，有人建议我们应该做一期关于最糟糕的国王和女王的节目，最糟糕的国王会非常搞笑，所以那会很有趣，不是吗？是的，这可能是我们可以期待的事情——所以我们要继续前进了。今天我们要谈论的国王们能够杀入这一轮已经做得很好了，但他们在第一个重大跨栏前摔倒了，所以我们应该列出种子选手，分别是伊丽莎白一世、
Henry VIII William I Victoria Edward III Charles II Elizabeth II that was the order and then the others were
亨利八世、威廉一世、维多利亚、爱德华三世、查理二世、伊丽莎白二世，这就是顺序，然后其他的有
Edward I, Henry II, Henry VII, Knut, Richard I, Cromwell, Athelstan, George V.
爱德华一世、亨利二世、亨利七世、克努特、理查德一世、克伦威尔、埃塞尔斯坦、乔治五世。
And the opening rounds, the first match to be played was Elizabeth I, the top seed, against Edward I. And unsurprisingly, absolutely hammered him. Absolutely hammered him. Soed him so the question here
而在开局的几轮中，进行的第一场比赛是头号种子伊丽莎白一世对阵爱德华一世。毫无意外，她把他彻底痛击了。绝对把他痛击了。所以问题就在于
is would which is appropriate because of course his nickname is hammer of the scots so the hammer got hammered was he going to lose no matter who he played in this round i think he probably was going to lose wasn't he ever the first he he was and i think one of the one of the things of course it's interesting is that if if you grow up in England, reading English books, going to English schools, is that you get an English perspective on your kings and queens. Of course.
这很贴切，因为他的绰号是苏格兰人的重锤，所以重锤挨锤了。不管他在这一轮遇到谁，他都会输吗？我想他大概率是要输的，不是吗，爱德华一世？他是的，而且我认为，其中一个有趣的地方在于，如果你在英格兰长大，读英国的书籍，上英国的学校，你会从英国的视角来看待你的国王和女王。当然。
And doing competition like this brings home very, very forcibly that people elsewhere may not entirely have quite the perspective that you do. And of course, Edward I is famous as Hammer of the Scots. He's Longshanks,
进行这样一场比赛，会非常有力地让你意识到，其他地方的人可能并不完全拥有和你一样的视角。当然，爱德华一世作为“苏格兰人的重锤”而闻名。他是长脚爱德华，
same name because he's enormous size the villain of braveheart yeah but he's also the king the english king that completed the english conquest of wales and so he's not regarded with huge enthusiasm in wales either uh so i think this the scots and the welsh were never going to rally behind him but an undeniably impressive king though tom i mean i know he crashed out but by medieval standards so he is in many ways the model of a medieval king isn't he edward i he comes in after his father henry iii who's been a bit of a sort of a bit useless a bit of a dithery sort of jelly um fighting simon de montfort and the barons
因为他身材高大，也是《勇敢的心》里的反派，对吧？但他也是完成了对威尔士征服的英国国王，所以他在威尔士也没有获得巨大的热情。因此，我认为苏格兰人和威尔士人绝不会支持他。不过，汤姆，他无疑是一位令人印象深刻的国王，我的意思是，我知道他出局了，但以中世纪的标准来看——所以在很多方面，他都是中世纪国王的典范，不是吗，爱德华一世？他在他父亲亨利三世之后登基，他父亲有点像个废物，有点优柔寡断像果冻一样……与西蒙·德·蒙福特和起诉他的男爵们战斗。爱德华一世——我没记错的话，他真正地重申了王权并某种程度上……
rising up against him edward i am i right in thinking that he really reasserts royal authority and sort of... Yeah, well, he's huge. He looks a king, kind of massive. He's been on a crusade. He's very good at fighting. And he's a very, very able administrator. And yes, absolutely. In a way, he's the kind of the model.
是的，嗯，他身材魁梧。他看起来像个国王，体型巨大。他参加过十字军东征。他非常擅长战斗。而且他是一个非常、非常能干的行政管理者。是的，绝对是。在某种程度上，他就是那种典范。
So you sent me some notes before we started. I'm not going to give away all our methods to the listeners. But when I look under Edward I, on the notes that you sent me, I see the words genital mutilation. What's all that about? Well, so one of the themes of medieval history, actually, no, I mean, it's a theme right the way through, is the awkward relationship that heirs to the throne tend to have with their predecessors. Yeah. And Edward initially causes trouble for his dad because his dad is facing a baron's rebellion led by a guy called Simon de Montfort. Yeah. And Edward initially sides with the rebellious barons, but he then changes sides, leads the royal forces, defeats Simon de Montfort at the Battle of evesham uh which is an incredibly bloody battle probably the bloodiest battle since hastings and uh simon de montfort dies in this battle
所以你在我们开始之前给我发了一些笔记。我不会向听众泄露我们所有的幕后方法。但当我在爱德华一世的名下查看你发给我的笔记时，我看到了“生殖器切除”这个词。这到底是怎么回事？好吧，中世纪历史的主题之一——其实，不，我的意思是，这是一个贯穿始终的主题——是王位继承人往往与他们的前任有着尴尬的关系。是的。爱德华最初给他的父亲制造了麻烦，因为他父亲面临着由一个叫西蒙·德·蒙福特的人领导的男爵叛乱。是的。而爱德华最初站在叛乱男爵一边，但他随后倒戈，领导了王室军队，在伊夫舍姆战役中击败了西蒙·德·蒙福特。这是一场极其血腥的战役，可能是自黑斯廷斯战役以来最血腥的战役，西蒙·德·蒙福特在这场战役中阵亡，
and he gets uh brute he he gets um dismembered mutilated and his genitals get hacked off all right well that's nice so touch isn't it so uh that's the kind of the measure of of edward edward doesn't do that personally presumably presumably. I think he probably orders it. The Lord Edward, as he's known. I mean, he's not a guy that you want to get on the wrong side of. He then goes on the crusade. Yep. He comes back.
他被——他被肢解、残害，生殖器也被砍掉了。好吧，这真是太美妙了。所以——爱德华的尺度就是这样，不是吗？爱德华大概不是亲自去做的吧，想必。我想他大概是下令这么做的。被称作“爱德华勋爵”的他。我的意思是，他可不是你想惹毛的人。然后他去参加了十字军东征。是的。他回来了。
He gets involved. Heading back to England, he gets involved in a massive tournament at Channels where various enemies try and gang up and murder him. But because he's tremendously cool and very good at fighting, he just wallops them. in a massive tournament at chanel where various enemies try and gang up and murder him but because he's because he's tremendously cool and very good at fighting he just wallops them right then he comes back to england gets crowned and it's just it's chaos because uh all the loads of scottish lords come and uh in the the party spirit they let all their horses loose so that people can you know you can pick up a horse and you can have it. And then all the English lords do it. So it's just London is
他卷入了——在返回英格兰的途中，他卷入了热讷（Chanles）的一场大型比武大会，在那里，各种敌人试图联合起来谋杀他。但因为他极其冷静且非常擅长战斗，他直接把他们痛打了一顿。在热讷的一场大型比武大会上，各种敌人试图联合起来谋杀他，但因为他极其冷静且非常擅长战斗，他直接把他们痛打了一顿。随后他回到英格兰加冕，那简直是一片混乱，因为——大批的苏格兰领主赶来，在聚会的精神下，他们放跑了所有的马，这样人们就可以，你知道的，你可以挑一匹马把它牵走。然后所有的英国领主也这么做了。所以伦敦到处都是
full of horses galloping everywhere. It's great fun. Right. Okay. That's a very strange, that just seems very strange. He gets crowned with the crown of Edward the Confessor. Because of the name? His name. Yes. Just a quick question about his name. Why is he called Edward? Henry III is a huge fan of Edward the Confessor, who has founded Westminster Abbey. And Henry III rebuilds Westminster Abbey. So the Westminster Abbey we have now is basically, it's Henry III's creation.
到处狂奔的马匹。这太有趣了。好吧。这真是太奇怪了，这看起来太奇怪了。他戴着爱德华忏悔者的王冠加冕。因为这个名字？他的名字。是的。关于他的名字有个小问题。他为什么叫爱德华？亨利三世是爱德华忏悔者的超级粉丝，爱德华忏悔者曾建立威斯敏斯特教堂。而亨利三世重建了威斯敏斯特教堂。所以我们现在看到的威斯敏斯特教堂基本上是亨利三世的杰作。
But Edward the Confessor's tomb lies at the heart of it. And so he names Edward after this Anglo-Saxon king. Isn't it a strange thing that Henry III, who is a bit of a drip, has this son who basically is, you know, Heracles, whose own son is then back to the drip again.
但爱德华忏悔者的陵墓位于它的核心。所以他用这位盎格鲁-撒克逊国王的名字给爱德华命名。亨利三世这个人有点像个漏水的滴水管，却有这样一个基本上是赫拉克勒斯般的儿子，而他自己的儿子却又退化回了滴水管，这难道不是很奇怪吗？
Yeah. There's this kind of cycle there, isn't there? There's a weird cycle. Yeah. Yeah. So Edward is, so one of the many,
是的。这里有一种那样的循环，不是吗？这是一个奇怪的循环。是的。是的。所以爱德华——《勇敢的心》弄错的众多事情之一，
many things that, that Braveheart gets wrong. And I always remember John O'Farrell's witty comment on it, that the only way it could be more inaccurate was if it featured a plasticine dog and was called William Wallace and Gromit. But one of the many ways it gets it wrong is that Edward is shown as sleeping around
我总是想起约翰·奥法尔（John O'Farrell）对此的精辟评论：唯一能让它更不准确的方法，就是加入一只塑胶泥狗，并把它命名为《威廉·华莱士与格罗米特》（William Wallace and Gromit）。它弄错的众多地方之一，就是爱德华被描绘成四处风流
and exercising Dorada Senor, but in fact, he's very, very... Luxurious. Like Nero, according to you. Like Nero, yes. So he married Eleanor of Castile uh and she died and he's so distraught that when her coffin is brought back he builds eleanor crosses the whole way yeah is that charing cross yes yes yeah it's that's a victorian kind of rebuilding of it i
和寻欢作乐的人，但事实上，他非常、非常——奢侈。像尼禄一样，根据你的说法。像尼禄一样，是的。所以他娶了卡斯蒂利亚的埃莉诺，她去世了，他悲痛欲绝，以至于当她的棺材运回来时，他沿途建造了埃莉诺十字架。是的，那是查令十字吗？是的，是的，那是维多利亚时代的重建。
think there are three that that basically survive um the the original one at Charing Cross was destroyed by Cromwell. So he obviously also conquers Wales. Conquers Wales, yep. And there's more genital mutilation there because he basically introduces hanging, drawing and quartering. And the brother of Llywelyn at Griffith, who is the last native,
我想基本上有三个幸存下来……查令十字的那个原件被克伦威尔摧毁了。所以他显然也征服了威尔士。征服了威尔士，是的。而且那里有更多的生殖器切除，因为他基本上引入了绞刑、剖腹和车裂。最后一位本土威尔士亲王、格鲁菲兹的勒埃利温（Llywelyn ap Gruffudd）的兄弟被俘虏、绞死、剖腹并车裂，而剖腹过程就包括生殖器切除。太棒了。此外，他在驱逐犹太人这件事上确实也有个污点，不是吗？他驱逐了犹太人。是的，他也这么做了。
the Welsh Prince of Wales, he gets captured, hung, drawn, courted, and the drawing involves genital mutilation. Nice. Also, he does have a bit of a blot on his discussion, doesn't he, about expelling the Jews? He expels the Jews. Yeah, he does that as well.
所以这与十字军东征周围滋生的反犹太主义气氛有关，是吗？你认为他深受其害吗？我认为这有帮助。我认为基本上他是想抢他们的钱，因为他一直在打这些仗。是的。所以他在打威尔士人，他在打苏格兰人。所以他需要钱。
So that's to do with the sort of anti-Semitic climate that's grown up around the Crusades, is it? Do you think that he's sort of drunk deeply of that? I think that helps. I think it's basically he wants to take their money because he's waging all these wars. Yeah. And so he's fighting the Welsh, he's fighting the Scots. So he needs the money.
所以基本上他抢了钱，把犹太人赶了出去。然后，当然，他继续需要钱。因此，爱德华一世的统治之所以如此重要，原因之一在于——其实，我们提到了西蒙·德·蒙福特，他在某种程度上传统上被视为议会之父。爱德华一世才是真正的议会之父，因为有一个关键的议会，即平民和贵族都参加的模范议会。这从根本上确立了议会应该同时包括平民和贵族的理念。对吧？所以非常、非常具有影响力……但是——我的意思是，显然不是一个非常、非常讨人喜欢的人，
So basically he grabs the money and chucks the Jews out. And then, of course, he continues to need money. And so one of the reasons why Edward I's reign is so important is that actually, we mentioned Simon de Montfort, who, in a way, is kind of traditionally cast as the father of parliaments. Edward I really is the father of parliaments, because there's one key parliament, the model parliament in which the commons as well as the lords come. And this essentially establishes the idea that parliaments should should should involve both commons and and lords right uh so very very influential um but um i mean not clearly not a very not a very pleasant man no but i mean very very powerful very domineering very effective uh very influential but but not the kind of guy who's going to be Elizabeth I.
不，但显然，正如你所说，尽管在各个方面都有令人不快之处，但毫无疑问，在同时代人眼中，他是一位极其令人印象深刻的国王，一个非常可怕的人物。我认为这就是国王应该有的样子的典范。是的。他在索尔韦湾的伯马什去世。任何沿着哈德良长城走过的人都会记得矗立在那里的纪念碑，那是他去世的地方。
No, but clearly, I mean, despite, as you say, unpleasantness in various areas, no doubt his contemporaries, an incredibly impressive king, you know, a very formidable figure. I think the kind of the model of what a king should be. Yeah. And he dies at Burmarsh, which is on the Solway Firth. And anyone who's walked along Hadrian's Wall will remember the memorial to him, to the place where he died, that stands there.
非常好。所以是个非常可怕的家伙。接下来退场的国王也是一位非常可怕的中世纪国王。可以说，有些人会说，撇开推特锦标赛不谈，他是绝对的24K金那种——顶级国王。顶级的决定性国王，亨利二世，他在1154年至1189年在位。所以他是伟大的……
Very nice. So very formidable fellow. And the next king to bow out was also a very formidable medieval king. Arguably, I mean, some people would say, Twitter tournaments aside, one of the absolute 24-carat sort of... Top kings. Top definitive kings, Henry II, who ruled from 1154 to 1189. So he's the great...
他输给了伊丽莎白二世，所以全都是“二世”，但太惊人了。他是一位伟大的、泰坦般的人物。我的意思是，他基本上是金雀花王朝的奠基人，不是吗？是的。是的，所以他的父亲——我的意思是，他基本上是金雀花王朝的奠基人，不是吗？是的。是的，所以他的父亲安茹的若弗鲁瓦（Geoffrey of Anjou）有一枝金雀花，在拉丁语中是 plantagenista。
He lost to Elizabeth II, so all the seconds, but amazing. He is a great, a titanic. I mean, he's the founder, basically, of the Plantagenets, isn't he? Yeah. Yeah, so his dad, mean, he's the founder, basically, of the Plantagenets, isn't he? Yeah. Yeah. So his dad, Geoffrey of Anjou, had a sprig of broom, which in Latin, plantagenista.
所以我们的一些听众会听说过斯蒂芬和玛蒂尔达之间的内战。基督和他的圣徒们都在睡觉。正是这样。无政府状态。那是无政府状态，不是吗？他们达成的某种交易是斯蒂芬当国王，玛蒂尔达的儿子亨利继位。所以亨利是统治者——他在法国拥有这些庞大的领地，也就是所谓的安茹帝国，但他同时也拥有英格兰。而他，再次成为了一位可怕的、革新的、强大的、中央集权的中世纪国王的绝对典范，不是吗，汤姆？
So some of our listeners will have heard of the civil war between Stephen and Matilda. Christ and his saints slept. Exactly. The anarchy. That's the anarchy, isn't it? And the sort of deal that they do is that Stephen will be king and Matilda's son, Henry, will succeed. So Henry is ruler of – he's got these vast possessions in France, the kind of Angevin Empire, but he's also got England. And he, again, is the absolute model, isn't he, Tom, of a formidable, reforming, powerful, centralising medieval king.
谋杀大主教。嗯，确实有这事。是的，确实有这事。好吧，你知道为什么我喜欢他吗？神圣属性？不，他不是很神圣。我的意思是，他谋杀了一位大主教。板球国王？
Archbishop murdering. Well, there is that. Yes, there is that. Well, you know why I'm keen on him? The sacral? No, he wasn't very sacral. I mean, he murdered an archbishop. Cricketing king?
索尔兹伯里。所以他最喜欢的地方之一是一个他将其建成宫殿的狩猎小屋，名叫克拉伦登（Clarendon），就坐落在索尔兹伯里郊外。他在那里颁布了著名的《克拉伦登宪法》。那不是其中一个……是的。
Salisbury. So one of his favourite places was a hunting lodge that he built into a palace called Clarendon, which stood just outside Salisbury. That's where he issues this famous, the Constitutions of Clarendon. Isn't that one of the... Yes.
所以他有点像爱德华。他是一位伟大的立法者。英国法律体系、普通法以及诸如此类的东西的起源通常都归功于他。而我没有足够的资格说这是否准确。但亨利试图将他的威权强加于英格兰的方式之一，就是通过控制神职人员免受世俗起诉的程度。他在1164年颁布了《克拉伦登宪法》，试图对神职人员和教皇等的权力施加限制。这就是与贝克特爆发决裂的地方，托马斯·贝克特。他最著名的事实是——我在舞台上扮演过他。
So he's a bit like Edward. He's a great lawgiver. And he's the kind of the origins of the English legal system, the common law and all that kind of thing is often attributed to him. And I'm not sufficiently qualified to say whether that's accurate or not. But one of the ways in which Edward is trying, Henry is trying to impose his authority on England is by reining in the degree to which clerics are kind of immune from secular prosecution. And he issues these Constitutions of Clarendon in 1164, which attempt to place limits on the authority of the clergy and the Pope and so on. And this is where the bust up with Beckett happens, Thomas Beckett. He's best known for the fact that I've played him on stage.
你扮演过？当然。是的，当然。十几岁的主教和运动鞋并没有准确传达中世纪教会的威严，苏格兰人报如是说。苏格兰人报懂什么？爱德华一世才不会理睬苏格兰人报呢。不，不，不。他会给我们一个好评的。
Have you? Of course. Yes, of course. Teenage bishops and trainers did not exactly convey the majesty of the medieval church, said the Scotsman. What does the Scotsman know? Edward I would have had no truck with the Scotsman. No, no, no. He'd have given us a great review.
好吧。所以快点，给我们讲讲亨利二世和托马斯的故事。哦，天哪。我真不该说这个。基于你扮演过他这一点。正如我所记得的——好吧，我把他演得非常、非常——很难在一个播客里概括它，因为它是一个如此复杂的——
Okay. So quickly, just tell us about Henry II and Thomas. Oh, God. I should never have said that. On the basis of you having played him. So as I recall, well, I played him as a very, very – it's hard to sum it up in one podcast, actually, because it was such a sophisticated –
丰富的细微差别。丰富的细微差别 portrayal（塑造）。所以贝克特有点像是他的化身，不是吗？他是他的好哥们儿。然后他成了一名神职人员。然后我所扮演的版本是——
Rich nuance. Rich nuance portrayal. So Beckett is kind of his creature, isn't he? He's his great pal. Then he becomes a cleric. And then the version that I was... Cardinal Wolsey. Exactly.
红衣主教沃尔西。正是如此。由法国剧作家让-亨利创作。贝克特随后有点基本上算是半个重生了什么的，我记得是这样。然后他皈依了教会的事业。他与国王决裂了。然后国王大名鼎鼎地派出了这些人——或者根本没有派他们，这取决于你相信什么。所以在此之前发生的事情是，贝克特勉强同意了《克拉伦登宪法》，然后走开了，接着决定他违背良心做错了事。
By the French playwright Jean-Henri. Beckett then kind of basically is sort of semi-born again or something, as I remember. And then is converted to the cause of the church. He falls out with the king. And then the king famously sends these men or doesn't send them, depending on what you believe. So what happens before that is that Becket reluctantly agrees to the constitutions of Clarendon, then goes away, then decides that he's done the wrong thing
亨利彻底勃然大怒。贝克特最后流亡国外，在那里他与法国国王套近乎，后者是亨利二世在法国的死敌。所以这可不是什么好事。贝克特回到了坎特伯雷。这一切都是通过谈判解决的。
with his conscience. Henry absolutely explodes. Becket ends up going into exile where he cozes up to the French king, who was the great rival of Henry II in France. So that doesn't go down well. Becket comes back to Canterbury. It's all been negotiated.
然后他——他有点，他做了什么？他有点拒绝做亨利想要他做的事。亨利勃然大怒，说出了类似于“谁能帮我摆脱这个暴躁的教士”的话。四个骑士冲了出去。他们把他砍倒了。那是哪一天？我想是12月29日。
He then, he kind of, what does he do? He kind of refuses to do something that Henry wants. And Henry explodes and says words to the effect of, who will rid me of this turbulent priest? And four knights rush off. And they cut him down. What is it? I think the 29th of December.
他们切掉他头顶上方的一部分来杀死他，就像切一个鸡蛋一样。好吧，正如老听众们所知，我在爱丁堡舞台上的这次非凡表演差点为我赢得了帕丁顿熊的角色。是的。因为那是执导帕丁顿熊电影的导演指导的。如果历史能走一条更好的路线的话。
And they kill him by slicing the top of his head off as though it were an egg. Well, as regular listeners will know this extraordinary portrayal on the stage in Edinburgh almost got me the role as Paddington. Yes. Because it was directed by the guy who went on to direct the Paddington films. And if only history had taken a better course.
我知道。汤姆会和本·威士肖一起做这个播客。而我则会扮演一只熊。一只秘鲁熊。我认为就凭这一点，亨利二世理应得到更好的待遇。是的。不过可能，可能他没有得到更好待遇的原因之一是，亨利二世是第一个干预爱尔兰的英国国王。对吧。我认为这并没有让他付出什么代价。
I know. Tom would be doing this podcast with Ben Whishaw. And I would be playing a bear. Peruvian bear. I think for that, Lady Henry II deserved to do better. Yes. Although possibly, possibly, one reason why he didn't do better is that Henry II is the English king who first intervenes in Ireland. Right. I don't think that cost him anything.
我知道，但这场世界杯一直挥之不去的背景是爱尔兰选民对英国历史上的某些人物有着正当的抱怨。基本上是所有人。嗯，克伦威尔显然在英国历史中占有一席之地。基本上是所有人。嗯，克伦威尔显然占有一席之地。伊丽莎白一世也是，当然。但亨利二世——实际上，我没看到任何人抱怨亨利二世。但在1171年，他发动了这次入侵。然后他把爱尔兰给了约翰。
I know, but a kind of rumbling backdrop to the World Cup has been Irish voters with justifiable complaints against certain figures in English history. Basically all of them. Well, Cromwell obviously featured English history. Basically all of them. Well, Cromwell obviously featured. Elizabeth I too, of course. But Henry II, actually, I didn't see anyone complaining about Henry II. But 1171, he leads this invasion. And then he gives Ireland to John.
这有点像是最糟糕的事。那是爱尔兰发生过的最糟糕的事，对吧？被交给约翰去盘剥。太可怕了。但是亨利——亨利为此付出了代价，因为他的儿子们背叛了他。他有他的妻子阿基坦的埃莉诺——是的，我们应该提到她，一个非常令人印象深刻的女人，绝对令人生畏。她确实令人印象深刻，但她也是个有点麻烦的女人，不是吗？我们能这么说吗？我不知道。嗯，她有点——我的意思是，她有点抛弃了她懦弱的法国国王丈夫，认为他太像个废柴了，于是跳船。她跟亨利二世同居，然后又背叛了他，鼓励他所有的儿子去反抗他。我的意思是，她确实令人印象深刻，但她也——有点像个噩梦。是的。但无论如何，亨利二世——
It's kind of the worst thing. That's the worst thing that's ever happened to Ireland, right? Being given to John to be counted terrible um but Henry Henry gets paid back for that because his sons turn against him uh he's got Eleanor of Aquitaine his wife yeah we should have mentioned her very impressive woman absolutely formidable she is impressive but she's also a bit of a baggage isn't she are we allowed to say that I don't know well she kind of i mean she's kind of goes off with her her wussy french king husband and decides that he's too much of a drip so jumps ship she shacks up with henry ii then turns against him encourages all his sons to rebel against her i mean she's she is impressive but she's all i mean kind of a bit of a nightmare yeah but anyway uh henry ii i
我认为在学校里没有人会仔细琢磨他，所以这有点像是一个标准的、令人印象深刻的中世纪国王模板，因此人们没有投票给他。你知道大卫·休谟是怎么评价他的吗？我知道，因为我把它写在下一页上了。好吧，你想读出来吗？好的。“就智慧、美德和能力而言，他是他那个时代最伟大的君主。”但大卫·休谟现在已经被取消了，不是吗？
think no one stutters him in schools so that's sort of an identikit, impressive medieval king, so people didn't vote for him. Do you know what David Hume said about him? I do, because I've got it written down on the next one. Okay, do you want to read it out? Yeah. The greatest prince of his time for wisdom, virtue, and abilities. But David Hume has been cancelled now, hasn't he?
所以，我的意思是，这不算数了？大卫·休谟无处不在。不，不，我认为这仍然算数。所以，这就是亨利二世的结局。汤姆，我们进度太慢了，因为汤姆半小时后还得去上广播节目，一个真正的广播节目。
So, I mean, that doesn't count. David Hume is around. No, no, I think that still counts. So, that's the end of Henry II. We are going far too slowly, Tom, because Tom's actually got to go on the radio, a real radio programme, in half an hour.
所以我们必须快点把它们过一遍。雷切尔，你会问的。所以亨利七世是下一个。现在，我是亨利七世的超级崇拜者。我认为他是一位非常令人印象深刻的国王。你知道还有谁吗？是的，我知道。好吧，所以有两个。
So we have to rattle through them. Rachel, you will ask. So Henry VII was the next. Now, I'm a huge admirer of Henry VII. I think he was a very impressive king. Do you know who else? Yeah, I do. Okay, so there are two.
目前英国文化生活中有两个关键人物。一个是乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）。是的，另一个是——好吧，所以有两个。目前英国文化生活中有两个关键人物。一个是乔纳森·威尔逊。是的，另一个是乔治·奥斯本（George Osborne）。另一个是乔治·奥斯本。他们两个。亨利七世是他们最喜欢的关键。亨利七世的崇拜者，是的。
There are two key figures in English cultural life at the moment. One is Jonathan Wilson. Yeah, and the other Okay, so there are two. There are two key figures in English cultural life at the moment. One is Jonathan Wilson. Yeah, and the other is George Osborne. The other is George Osborne. Both of them. Henry VII is their favourite key. Henry VII admirers, yes.
而原因很明显，那就是亨利七世以对金钱谨慎而闻名。对金钱谨慎。是的，我不会——我的意思是，乔纳森·威尔逊可能会被冒犯。但我认为乔纳森·威尔逊以非常——他是一个精明干练的操盘手而闻名。是的，我不会——我的意思是，乔纳森·威尔逊可能会被冒犯，但我认为乔纳森·威尔逊以非常——他是一个精明干练的操盘手而闻名。是的，一个精明干练的操盘手，是的。
And the reason for that, obviously, is that Henry VII is famously careful with his money. Careful with his money. Yeah, I'm not going to – I mean, Jonathan Wilson may take offence. But I think Jonathan Wilson is well-known for being a very – he's very canny. He's a canny operator. Yeah, I'm not going to... I mean, Jonathan Wilson may take offence, but I think Jonathan Wilson is well known for being a very... He's very canny. He's a canny operator. Yeah, a canny operator, yeah.
所以，是的，亨利七世基本上是一个冒险家，不是吗？他通过一连串非常严重且复杂的家族树恶作剧，从玫瑰战争中幸存下来。他是最后一位基本上幸存的兰开斯特王位继承人，这样说公平吗？我的意思是，我知道我大大简化了——是的，所以约克家族以爱德华四世的形式接管了权力，然后是他的儿子爱德华五世，他在伦敦塔中神秘失踪，理查德三世接管了权力——所以兰开斯特家族基本上已经被消灭了——但你确实有了亨利，他是欧文·都铎的孙子，欧文诡异地娶了法国的凯瑟琳，后者曾嫁给亨利五世。
So, yes, Henry VII is basically an adventurer, isn't he? He's sort of left over from the Wars of the Roses through a very serious of complicated kind of family tree shenanigans. He's the last basically surviving Lancastrian claimant is that fair i mean i know i'm massively simplifying yeah so the york is york is take over in the in the form of edward the fourth then edward the fifth his son who then vanishes in the tower and richard the third takes over um so the lancastrians have basically been wiped out uh but you do have henry and he is uh the grandson of owenor, who married, weirdly, Catherine of France, who married Henry V.
我的意思是，这真是一次大降级，不是吗？他真的为自己干得不错。法国的凯瑟琳，真的干得不错。而且欧文和欧文的儿子，也就是未来亨利七世的父亲埃德蒙，都被约克家族杀害了。但亨利的关键人物、他成为王位觊觎者的根本原因在于，他的母亲玛格丽特·博福特（Margaret Beaufort）是通过冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt）后代传承自爱德华三世。她生他的时候才 13 岁。我知道。这有点吓人，不是吗？
Yeah. I mean, that's quite a come down, isn't it? He's really done well for himself. Catherine of France, really done well. And both Owen and Owen's son, so future Henry VII's father, Edmund, they're both killed by Yorkists. But the key figure for Henry and basically the reason why he becomes the pretender is that his mother, Margaret Beaufort, is descended from Edward III via John of Gaunt. And she had him when she was 13. I know. That's kind of scary, isn't it?
无论如何，所以她显然在栽培他，不是吗？她把他推向前台。她提拔他。她拥有所有的人脉。是的。所以他在1471年逃往法国。他基本上——他根本不是一个重要的玩家，对吧？我认为他的重要性足以让约克家族的国王们试图除掉他。
Anyway, so she obviously builds him up, doesn't she? She pushes him forward. She promotes him. She has all the contacts. Yeah. So he flees to France in 1471. And he's kind of, he's not really a significant player at all, is he? I think he's significant enough that the Yorkist kings are trying to get rid of him.
所以他不得不经常搬迁。他从勃艮第搬到法国。但那真的只是因为他是最后一个散落的线索。并不是因为他有什么作为了不起家伙的名誉——他只是最后一个剩下的，直到理查德三世篡位——是的，绝对如此。正是在那时，约克家族的一切开始分崩离析，因为人们对发生的事情感到真正的震惊，于是白金汉公爵发起了最初的起义，与亨利七世联合，但他发动得太早了。
And so he's constantly kind of having to move. He moves from Burgundy to France. But that's really because he's the last loose end. It's not because he has any reputation as a tremendous fellow he's just the last remaining until richard iii's usurpation yeah exactly exactly and that is when it all starts to fall to pieces for the yorkists because people are genuinely shocked by what's happened and so you have the duke of buckingham he launches this initial revolt in association with Henry VII but he launches it too soon
白金汉被谋杀了，被抓起来处决了，他的鬼魂至今还在索尔兹伯里的德本汉姆百货公司（Debenhams）游荡。我还在想你为什么要扯进这个白金汉的兔子洞里，原来是为了提到索尔兹伯里的德本汉姆。他显然在内衣部游荡。凯尔·萨布里兹（Kel Sabreeze），像《泰德神父》（Father Ted）一样。
Buckingham gets murdered, gets caught executed and his ghost to this day haunts Debenhams in Salisbury I wondered why you were going on this Buckingham rabbit hole so you could mention Debenhams in Salisbury he haunts the lingerie department apparently Kelser Breeze like Father Ted He haunts the lingerie department, apparently. Kel Sabreeze.
他显然在内衣部游荡。凯尔·萨布里兹，像《泰德神父》一样。所以，亨利七世入侵了。他率领着这支杂牌军。他们在米尔福德海文（Milford Haven）登陆。1485年。斯坦利家族倒戈。理查德三世被杀。我们明年将做一个关于伦敦塔中小王子的播客。我们已经把它记在日程上了，所以我们不会深入太多细节。
Like Father Ted. So, Henry VII invades. He leads this kind of ragtag band. They arrive at Bostwick. 1485. The Stan is changed sides. Richard III is killed. We're going to do a podcast about the princes and the tower next year. We have it in the diary, so we won't go into too much detail.
亨利七世的王冠在山楂丛中被找到，戴在头上。他成为了国王。迎娶了约克家族的伊丽莎白。是的，他这么做了，为了团结兰开斯特。所以红白玫瑰在都铎玫瑰中合二为一。然后，在经历了这段基本上长达70年、或者说——我的意思是，漫长而相对混乱、并以玫瑰战争达到高潮的时期之后，
Henry VII, crown found in Hawthorne Bush, put on head. He is king. Marries Elizabeth of York. Yes, he does, to unite Lancaster. So the red and white rose are united in the Tudor rose. And then after this dreadful period of basically 70 years, or, well, I mean, a long period of relative chaos, which had culminated in the Wars of the Roses,
亨利七世真正恢复了稳定，他严厉打击了男爵们。嗯，这事其实还在继续发酵，不是吗？它还在发酵。确实如此。所以他们并不知道玫瑰战争
Henry VII really restores stability and he cracks down on the barons. Well, it kind of rumbles on though, doesn't it? It rumbles on. It does. So they don't know the Wars of the Roses
已经在1485年结束了。不，但它们并没有完全结束，因为你遇到了兰伯特·西姆尔（Lambert Simnel），他假冒沃里克伯爵，并在斯托克战役中被击败。他最后是不是成了一个糕点厨师什么的？
have ended in 1485. No, but they haven't entirely ended because you get Lambert Simnel, who pretends to be the Earl of Warwick and who gets defeated at the Battle of Stoke. Doesn't he end up being a pastry cook or something?
是的，一个烤肉叉转动工。他在厨房里转动烤肉叉，然后是珀金·沃贝克（Perkin Warbeck），他声称自己是伦敦塔中的小王子，结果被处决了。所以你还有他们——但是，是的，基本上——哦，他建立了近卫军（Yeoman of the Guard），真不错，在伦敦塔。但他非常擅长——他整理了王室财政，这曾是一个如此巨大的问题——他——他因为苛捐杂税而不受欢迎，所以他得到了他的“莫顿叉”——是的，基本上“莫顿”是他的大臣之一，如果你看起来很富有，那么你显然有很多钱，你应该给国王交更多的税；如果你看起来很穷，那么你
Yes, a spit. He turns to spits right in the kitchens and then perking warbeck who claims to be the younger of the princes in the tower and he gets executed so you've got them but yes basically oh and he founds the um the yeoman of the guard nice in the tower but he's very good with he sorts out the royal finances which have been such a problem uh he is he's he's disliked for his heavy taxes so he gets his fork yes so basically morton's fork is if you look morton is one of his ministers if you if you appear to be rich then you obviously have lots of money and you should give more tax to the king if you appear to be poor then you're
显然在藏匿你所有的钱——是的，你也应该给国王交更多的税。所以你可以理解为什么乔治·奥斯本是他的超级粉丝了。但他——是的，他很聪明，他很阴险，不是吗？嗯，但他不——他既不贪婪，也不是暴君。我认为他很贪婪。我不认为他很贪婪。我认为他很精明。
obviously hiding all your money yeah you should also give more tax for the king so you can see why George Osborne is such a fan but he yes he's clever he's sinister isn't he well but he's not he's not rapacious and he's not tyrannical I think he's rapacious I don't think he's rapacious I think he's canny
你读过汤姆·佩恩（Tom Penn）的精彩著作《寒冬之王》（Winter King）吗？《寒冬之王》，完全正确。因为那本书写得非常好——我的意思是，把他塑造成了一个阴险的人物。我认为他把他塑造成了阴险的人物，但我认为他稍微有点夸大了阴险的那一面。我认为对于许多人来说，在经历了过去几十年的动荡之后，亨利七世带来了受欢迎的、非常受欢迎的稳定。好吧，我——我接受这一点。但我也认为他身上有一种稍微有点阴险吝啬的品质，这解释了——显然选民们也同意这一点——解释了他为什么输给亨利五世。
have you read Tom Penn's wonderful book Winter King Winter King exactly yes because that gives very good i mean makes him a sinister figure i think he makes him sinister but i think he slightly overdoes the sinister aspect i think for a lot of people after the turmoil of the previous decades henry the seventh provided welcome very welcome stability okay i i i accept that but i also think that there is a kind of slightly sinister mean quality to him that explains well clearly the voters agreed with explains why he lost to Henry V.
是的，有道理。好吧。汤姆，我们在中场休息前还得再讲一个。哦，天哪。好吧，让我们加快速度。所以是威廉一世对阵克努特。11世纪入侵者和英格兰征服者之间一场非常有趣的碰撞。是的。
Yes, fair enough. Okay. So we have to do one more before the break, Tom. Oh, goodness. Okay, well, let's speed up. So William I against Cnut. So interesting clash of 11th century invaders and conquerors of England there. Yes.
维京血统。克努特赢了。这是一场非常、非常激烈的战斗。克努特仅仅惜败。是的，克努特仅仅惜败，不是吗？所以很多人，你叫他克努特（Cnut），但我们大多数人称他为卡努特（Canute），就像瓢虫一样。
A Viking heritage. Cnut won. It was a very, very tight battle. Cnut only just lost. Yeah, Cnut only just lost, didn't he? So a lot of people, you call him Cnut, but most of us know him as Canute, which is the ladybird.
嗯，Cnut 这个词引发了不可避免的笑话。这就是你这么做的原因吗？不，因为他本来就叫 Cnut。卡努特（Canute）是后来的加里西亚语化发音，所以他是——丹麦人，不是吗？叉须斯韦恩（Sweyn Forkbeard）的儿子。叉须斯韦恩，也就是蓝牙哈拉尔（Harold Bluetooth）的儿子，节目的老朋友，对吧？那个在拉屎的时候屁股中箭的维京国王。是的——叉须斯韦恩，一个可怕的国王，留着胡子。是分叉的。来到英格兰，征服了英格兰……但在他成为国王之前就死了。不，他确实成了国王。他赶走了
Well, Cnut prompts the inevitable joke. Is that why you're doing it? No, because he was Cnut. Canute is a later Gallicism so he's uh danish isn't he son of svain forkbeard svain forkbeard who is son of harold bluetooth friend of the show yeah the viking king who got shot in the ass while having a dump yeah uh svain forkbeard terrifying king had a beard it was forked came over to england conquered england um but dies before he can become king he does become king he forces out Sveinforkbeard, terrifying king, had a beard. It was forked. Came over to England, conquered England. But dies before he can become king.
埃塞尔雷德无准备者。他逃到了国外。叉须斯韦恩当了大约五周的英格兰国王。根据后来的传说，他死了，因为圣埃德mund——他在对圣埃德mund出言不逊。圣埃德mund告诉他——非常礼貌地告诉他停下来。叉须斯韦恩基本上说，滚蛋吧。所以埃德mund杀了。
No, he does become king. He forces out Æthelred the Unready. He flees abroad. Sveinforkbeard is king of England for about five weeks. And he dies according to later tradition because St. Edmund, he's being rude about St. Edmund. St. Edmund tells him,'s being rude about Saint Edmund. Saint Edmund tells him, very politely tells him to stop. Svein Forkbeard basically says, piss off. And so Edmund kills him.
这里写着：“在他头上狠狠打了一下，不久之后他便因疼痛而死。”是的。好吧，所以被一个圣人打在头上。所以叉须斯韦恩死了。然后卡努特接管了权力。卡努特是斯卡尔德吟游诗人的一位伟大英雄，他们赞美他，当他——他非常年轻，非常有早熟的掠夺者特质，只是个男孩：“当你下水时，没有国王比你更年轻，你这个船只摧毁者。”
It struck him on the head a blow from the pain of which he shortly afterwards died, it says here. Yeah. Right, so slapped on the head by a saint. So that's spain dead so canute then takes over and there's this canute is a kind of great uh hero of the scaldic bards um and they him him when he's he's kind of very he's very young he's very precocious kind of raider only a boy you ship batterer when you launched your boat no king was younger than you
然后卡努特与埃塞尔雷德无准备者的儿子埃德蒙·艾恩赛德（Edmund Ironside）战斗。基本上这是一场平局，他们把英格兰瓜分了……埃德蒙随后在1016年去世，据信又有点像蓝牙哈拉尔——在拉屎的时候。哦，据说是一根矛从厕所的洞里刺穿上来，刺进他的屁股里。所以他就这样挂了，然后卡努特接管了英格兰。起初他糟糕透顶，强加了100%的税率——所以那非常——整个英格兰的税收收入——那非常——带着它跑路了——那非常像是1975年左右的丹尼斯·希利（Denis Healey），如果他把税率提高到98%的话——是的，嗯，我记得最高所得税率是83%。98%是针对非劳动所得的。但有趣的是，在经历了一番嗜血杀戮之后
and canute fights with um athelred the unready son edmund ironside they basically it's a score draw they divide england up um edmund then uh dies in in 1016 supposedly again a bit like um harold bluetooth uh having a dump oh that's supposedly spiked through a hole in the privy spear up up into his ass so that's him done and um canute then takes over england and to begin with he's absolutely terrible and he imposes this 100 tax rate so that's very the entire tax revenue of england that's very makes off with it that's very dennis healy circa 1975 if he went to 98 didn't he yeah yes yeah that's well 83 i think was the top income tax rate. 98% was on unearned income. But interestingly, so having been murderous
克努特与埃塞尔雷德·无准备者之子埃德蒙·铁侧作战，基本上打成了平手，他们把英格兰分成了两半。埃德蒙随后在1016年去世，据传又是像哈拉尔·蓝牙上厕所那样——据说是在厕所的洞里被长矛从下体刺了进去，就这样一命呜呼了。然后克努特接管了英格兰，一开始他表现得极其糟糕，征收了100%的税率，也就是把英格兰整年的税收收入全部卷走。这非常符合1975年前后的丹尼斯·希利风格，他把税率提高到了98%，不是吗？对，是的，那是...我觉得最高所得税率是83%，98%是对非劳动所得征收的。但有趣的是，在经历了残暴的统治之后
and kind of just nicking everything, Canute then becomes a really good king. So there's a very good Archbishop of York called Wolfstan, as Archbishops of York tend to be. And he gets Canute to swear to uphold the laws of the Anglo-Saxon kings, to be a good king. Canute is actually a very devout Christian. He marries Æthelred's widow, Emma, the daughter of the Duke of Normandy.
克努特把一切都搜刮一空后，竟然变成了一个非常好的国王。约克有一位非常优秀的红衣大主教叫沃尔夫斯坦，约克的红衣大主教往往都是如此。他让克努特发誓维护盎格鲁-撒克逊国王的法律，做一个好国王。克努特其实是一个非常虔诚的基督徒。他娶了埃塞尔雷德的遗孀、诺曼底公爵的女儿埃玛。
So there's a bit of continuity there. Tom, please tell me about the waves. I mean, everyone wants to know about the waves. I think we should focus on more important things, like he was a great patron of Wililton three miles from where i grew up so he went he went on pilgrimage to rome in 27 got kind of lauded by the pope by the emperor and everybody uh buried in winchester so a good a good king by english standards right and the of course for which he is known is the story that um he stands on the
所以那里有点连贯性。汤姆，请跟我讲讲海浪的事。我的意思是，每个人都想知道海浪的事。我觉得我们应该关注更重要的事情，比如他是威尔顿的伟大赞助人，离我长大的地方只有三英里，所以他在27年去罗马朝圣，受到教皇、皇帝和所有人的赞赏，呃，安葬在温彻斯特，所以按英国标准来说是一个好国王，对吧？当然，他最著名的故事是，呃，他站在
on the beach and tries to stop the waves and that's a story that originates in the 12th century with henry of huntingdon yeah and it's an illustration of the fact that not that canute is kind of insanely uh arrogant and thinks that he can stop the waves it's exactly the opposite um he's showing because flatterers are saying to him uh you you know you're the great king you can do anything you like. And Canute demonstrates by his failure to hold back the waves that only God can do. Well, I think that's, even if he didn't do it, it's still laudable. And display of modesty that never happened, that we can all learn from.
海滩上，试图阻止海浪。这个故事起源于12th世纪的亨廷顿的亨利，是的，这说明了一个事实，并不是说克努特有点疯狂地傲慢，以为他可以阻止海浪。恰恰相反，呃，他展示了，因为奉承者对他说，呃，你知道的，你是伟大的国王，你可以做任何你喜欢的事。而克努特通过他未能阻挡海浪的事实表明，只有上帝才能做到。嗯，我觉得，即使他没有这样做，这也是值得称赞的。这是一种从未发生过的谦逊表现，我们都可以从中学习。
And he absolutely should have beaten William the Conqueror, in my view. Just a far better man. Now, we will have to take a break, and we will return to do this. While the waves lap around the legs of Tom Holland's throne, we will have some advertising and promote things, and then we shall return and talk about the four remaining losers from this round. And we shall see you after the break.
依我看，他绝对应该打败征服者威廉。他只是一个好得多的人。现在，我们得休息一下，然后回来继续。当海浪拍打着汤姆·霍兰德王座的腿时，我们将做一些广告和宣传，然后我们将回来讨论这轮剩下的四个失败者。我们休息后再见。
Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our q&a, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club. If you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to the rest of the entertainment.comcom that's therestisentertainment.com now regular listeners will be familiar with our splendid promotional efforts for unheard and how do you spell that dominic i spell it u-n-h-e-r-d.com they're very keen on the spellings they've they've
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻评论、八卦花边的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。现在，老听众一定对我们对 UnHerd 的精彩宣传工作不陌生了，那个怎么拼来着，多米尼克？我拼作 u-n-h-e-r-d.com。他们对拼写非常执着，他们把
written that in blue for us to spell out so it's the online magazine you may remember it pushes back against herd mentality and is passionate about independent thinking and sponsoring our podcast very kindly and both of us have written for unheard haven't we tom yeah absolutely which is why very kindly they're offering a special deal to all you listeners out there, Restless History listeners. Three months free subscription, which can be cancelled at any time. It's normally one pound, I guess. Is that a month, a week?
这个词写成蓝色让我们拼出来，所以这是一个你可能还记得的网络杂志，它反对羊群效应，热心于独立思考，并非常友好地赞助了我们的播客。我们两个都为 UnHerd 写过稿，对吧，汤姆？是的，绝对的。这就是为什么他们非常友善地为你们所有的听众、历史就是一切的听众提供特别优惠。三个月的免费订阅，可以随时取消。通常是一英镑，我猜。是一周还是一个月？
A week, I guess. It's one pound a week, the producer is telling me. One pound a week. We're so on top of our brief here. But what I can tell you is that if you want to claim it, you go to unheard.com forward slash rest. And each week we will pull out some highlights from UnHerd that rest is history. Yes. Might enjoy. Yes.
我想是一周。制作人告诉我是一周。一周一英镑。我们对这个简报真是了如指掌。但我能告诉你的是，如果你想领取优惠，你可以去 unheard.com 斜杠 rest。每周我们都会从历史就是一切的 UnHerd 中挑选一些精彩内容。是的。你可能会喜欢。是的。
And this week, of course, Dominic, we've been talking kings and queens. We are talking kings and queens. We're in the middle of the episode. We're doing it right now. And there's a fabulous article written by Henry Oliver about. Named after two kings, of course. Yeah. One uncrowned very very good uh and that is about king charles the third do you think he will be king charles
本周，当然，多米尼克，我们一直在谈论国王和女王。我们在谈论国王和女王。我们正处于节目的中间。我们现在就在做这件事。亨利·奥利弗写了一篇极好的文章关于。当然是以两个国王命名的。是的。一个未加冕的，非常非常好的，那就是关于查理三世国王。你觉得他会是查理三世吗？
the third well he's talking about changing his name isn't he yeah i think what would maybe to athelstan the second that would be good wouldn't it that would be great very satisfying but um and and um it's it's a kind of comparison about how he might operate and actually how he might be quite like george v well as you will discover in this podcast that is a tremendous thing to be wears his trousers correctly yes keen on shoes stamps so um essentially charles iii may be may be okay as as king is that sounds great i'm looking forward to it already yeah uh and then also uh i think even even more an even better article i mean it's well this it's it's
嗯，他在谈论改名字，不是吗？是的，我想或许改成埃塞尔斯坦二世？那不是很好吗？那会很棒，非常令人满意。但是，嗯，嗯，这是一个关于他如何运作以及实际上他可能非常像乔治五世的比较。正如你在这个播客中所发现的，成为那样的人是一件了不起的事情。他的裤子穿得很对，是的，喜欢鞋子和邮票。所以，本质上，查理三世作为国王也许，也许还可以。听起来很棒，我已经开始期待了。是的，然后还有，我觉得甚至，甚至还有一篇更好的文章，我的意思是，这，这，
an absolutely wonderful article you couldn't really read anything better it's by the wonderful kostika uh bradatan uh who's written an essay privileges the new original sin um and do you know what he argues dominic it sounds a terrible argument i mean he argues yeah he argues, Dominic? It sounds a terrible argument. I mean, I know you're unheard. He argues, and I'm reading here, that today's progressives are as steeped in Christian ideas as both their capitalist and communist forebears. Wow. And who does he reference? What top authorities does he reference in this article? I believe that he references a top historian
这是一篇绝对精彩的文章，你真的读不到比这更好的了。它是伟大的科斯蒂卡·布拉达坦写的，他写了一篇题为《特权是新的原罪》的文章。你知道他的论点是什么吗，多米尼克？听起来是个糟糕的论点。我的意思是，他争辩说，是的，他争辩说，多米尼克？听起来是个糟糕的论点。我的意思是，我知道你在 UnHerd。他的论点是，我在这里读到，今天的进步人士和他们的资本主义以及共产主义前辈一样，都深受基督教思想的影响。哇。他参考了谁？他在本文中参考了哪些顶级权威？我相信他参考了一位顶级历史学家。
who has written the history of Christianity and which goes on about it in podcasts. Yes. No lesser person than Tom Holland, friend of the rest is history. So that is why I have absolutely no hesitation in unreservedly recommending UnHerd, U-N-H-E-R-D. Do spell it out. Yeah. UnHerd.com slash rest.
他写过基督教史，并在播客中滔滔不绝地谈论它。是的。不是别人，正是“历史就是一切”的朋友汤姆·霍兰德。这就是为什么我毫不犹豫地、毫无保留地推荐 UnHerd，U-N-H-E-R-D。一定要拼出来。是的。UnHerd.com 斜杠 rest。
Go and join the UnHerd. Well, they'll have a herd if too many people they don't want that but let's hope that a substantial minority so that we can carry on a countercultural minority okay uh back to the kings and queens thanks a lot bye welcome back to the rest is history uh we are are talking about the losers in the first round of the World Cup of Kings and Queens, and we are on to the Lionheart himself, Richard I. Tom, were you surprised to see Richard the Lionheart bowing out so soon? Not really, because we talked about doing the worst kings and queens of England.
去加入 UnHerd 吧。如果人太多，他们就会有一群人了，他们不希望那样，但我们希望有相当大的一部分少数群体，这样我们就可以继续维持一个反文化的少数群体。好了，回到国王和女王身上，非常感谢，再见。欢迎回到《历史就是一切》，我们正在谈论国王和女王世界杯第一轮的失败者，我们接下来要谈的是狮心王理查一世。汤姆，看到狮心王理查这么快就被淘汰，你感到意外吗？不太意外，因为我们谈过评选英国最糟糕的国王和女王。
I think Richard would be a candidate for that as well. I think he's probably the only one who'd feature prominently in both. He's sort of wrong but romantic, isn't he, in he's a very he's um he's he's a very he's a very glamorous figure yeah but he's he's also everyone knows he's terrible so stephen rutzeman the great historian of the of the crusades said that he was a bad son a bad husband a bad king but a gallant and splendid soldier so his rule is king for 10 years and of those 10 years he spends 10 months in england and and the rest of it is basically crusades isn't it and and being captured and and locked up in in uh austria or whatever it is he marries berengaria of navarre who is um famously
我想理查也是其中的候选人。我想他可能是唯一一个在这两项评选中都显著出现的人。他有点错误但很浪漫，不是吗？他是一个非常，他是一个，他是一个非常迷人的人物，是的，但他也，每个人都知道他很糟糕。因此，十字军东征的伟大历史学家史蒂文·朗西曼说，他是一个坏儿子，一个坏丈夫，一个坏国王，但却是一个勇敢而灿烂的士兵。因此，他的国王统治了10年，在这10年中，他在英格兰呆了10个月，其余时间基本上都在进行十字军东征，不是吗？并且被俘虏，关在奥地利什么的。他娶了纳瓦拉的贝伦加利亚，她
reputedly the only queen of england never to have set foot in England. And she features in, I think, is it Lion in Winter? And she has the immortal line, war. What is it, Dominic? It's your favourite one. War, war, war. That's all you care about, Dick Plantagenet. That's right. Exactly.
据说是唯一一个从未踏足英格兰的英国王后。她出演了，我想，是《冬狮》吗？她有一句不朽的台词：战争。是什么，多米尼克？这是你最喜欢的那句。战争，战争，战争。这就是你关心的全部，迪克·金雀花。没错。完全正确。
And that's pretty much, I mean, that's pretty accurate. Basically, fighting is all he does. So he's born in England, but he spends very little time in England. He's basically in Aquitaine with his mum. Yeah. And he just fights. He's just obsessed with the crusades isn't he he fight well he's he fights against his dad yeah he's poor henry the second i mean henry the second basically dies of of despair and grief because richard is such a nightmare and then no soon as you become king then he's basically trying to flog london and raise vast amounts of money so he can fund a crusade so he goes off on the third crusade and he's a tremendous success on that i
这差不多就是，我的意思是，这相当准确。基本上，打仗就是他所做的一切。所以他出生在英格兰，但在英格兰呆的时间很少。他基本上和他的妈妈在阿基坦。是的。他只是打仗。他简直对十字军东征着迷了，不是吗？他打得很好。他反对他的父亲。是的，可怜的亨利二世，我的意思是，亨利二世基本上死于绝望和悲伤，因为理查是个十足的噩梦。然后你刚一成为国王，他基本上就试图拍卖伦敦并筹集巨额资金，以便他能资助一次十字军东征。所以他参加了第三次十字军东征，并在那次东征中取得了巨大的成功。我的意思
mean he doesn't capture jerusalem but he captures acre he's he he gets him he becomes admired by saladin defeat saladin great star i mean he's very brutally slaughters lots of prisoners but he blazes a path. He cuts a dash. But all the other European monarchs hate him, don't they? The fellow from Austria, Leopold, and Philip of France. Well, yes, because they capture Acre. They capture Acre.
是，他没有攻占耶路撒冷，但他攻占了阿卡，他赢得了萨拉丁的钦佩，击败了萨拉丁，了不起的明星。我的意思是，他非常残忍地屠杀了很多囚犯，但他开辟了一条道路。他气宇轩昂。但所有其他的欧洲君主都讨厌他，不是吗？奥地利的那个家伙，利奥波德，还有法国的菲利普。嗯，是的，因为他们占领了阿卡。他们占领了阿卡。
And he's there with Philip II of France, Philip Augustus, and Leopold of Austria. And the three of them put up their banners. And Philip and Richard are furious because Leopold of Austria isn't a king so they hurl it down Richard hurls it down into the mud and then when he comes back from the crusade of course he gets captured yeah and Leopold takes him prisoner and so all Richard's subjects in France and England have to raise another massive amount of money to get him out. Yeah, that's poor behaviour.
他与法兰西国王菲利普二世（即菲利普·奥古斯都）和奥地利的利奥波德在那里。他们三人挂出了他们的旗帜。菲利普和理查大发雷霆，因为奥地利的利奥波德不是国王，所以他们把它扯了下来。理查把它扔进泥里，然后当他从十字军东征回来时，理查当然被俘虏了。利奥波德把他抓了起来，所以理查在法国和英格兰的所有臣民不得不筹集另一笔巨款来把他赎出来。是的，这表现太差了。
I mean, I can't imagine the current Queen behaving that way. No. And Philip II, who's his compadre on the crusade, but is his great rival because Philip wants to take back the Angevin Empire. And he's been working in cahoots with John, who everyone will remember from Walt Disney as the evil cowardly lion um philip when when when richard the lionheart finally gets released sends this message look to yourself the devil is loose but what do people in england think of i think they
我的意思是，我无法想象现在的女王会那样做。是的。菲利普二世，他在十字军东征中的密友，但也是他最大的对手，因为菲利普想要收回安茹帝国。他一直在与约翰暗中勾结，沃尔特·迪斯尼的每个人都会记得约翰是个邪恶懦弱的狮子。菲利普，当狮心王理查终于被释放时，发出了这样的信息：当心你自己，恶魔被释放了。但是英格兰的人民对理查有什么看法？我想他们
think he's kind of dashing but a bit of a pain but i think the the the long run the evidence for what people in england think about him is all those stories that that the robin hood stories yeah where it's richard the lionheart turns up and he's the absolute hero and he saves the day so sean connery in yes exactly exactly robin connery bizarrely playing an english king yes yeah yeah um so that's richard the lionheart so that suggests the people actually quite like him but obviously not enough to um oh and he gets he he um he he founds this great castle chateau gay are which kind of provides you know it's the cutting edge of castle technology and then he's besieging a rather useless
认为他有点潇洒，但也有点令人头疼。不过我认为，长期来看，关于英格兰人对他的看法的证据就是所有那些罗宾汉的故事。是的，罗宾汉的故事中，狮心王理查出现了，他是绝对的英雄，他拯救了世界。所以肖恩·康纳利在，是的，完全正确，罗宾·康纳利古怪地扮演了一个英国国王。是的，是的，嗯，那是狮心王理查，这表明人们其实挺喜欢他的，但显然不足以，哦，他建立这座宏伟的城堡盖雅城堡，这有点提供，你知道的，它是城堡技术的尖端，然后他在围攻一个相当没用的
castle where he gets shot by a boy that's right parents dies in such a banal way yeah he just gets shot through and that richard's last um dying last dying words is that he forgives the boy when it's brought before him. Which is very touching. But do you know what then happens? The boy is hung, drawn and quartered? He's flayed. He's flayed alive. Isn't there a quick question?
城堡时，被一个男孩开枪击中了。没错，父母以如此平庸的方式死去。是的，他中枪了，理查的最后遗言是，当这个男孩被带到他面前时，他原谅了男孩。这非常感人。但你知道接下来发生了什么吗？这个男孩被施以绞刑、剖腹和分尸？他被剥皮了。他被活剥了皮。难道没有一个简短的问题吗？
Before we move on, isn't there a question about Richard's sexuality? Yes. So some historians argue that he was gay. others say that uh he it's this is anachronistic uh yeah i mean how can they possibly know i mean what are they basing this on i suppose the fact that he didn't have a child with his with berengaria right but i mean that's he did he did he did he certainly fathered fathered certainly i think one child right okay so he didn't win anyway so that's enough of him now let's talk about our next king or was he a king certainly off of the crown um certainly filled the the boots of a king uh he is of course ollie oliver cromwell um who was my tip
在我们继续之前，难道没有关于理查性取向的问题吗？是的。所以一些历史学家认为他是同性恋。其他人则说，呃，这是时代错置。是的，我的意思是，他们怎么可能知道？我的意思是，他们这是基于什么？我想是因为他和贝伦加利亚没有孩子，对吧？但我的意思是，他确实，他确实，他当然生了，当然生了一个孩子，对吧？好吧，所以他无论如何也没有赢。好了，关于他就到这里，现在我们来谈谈我们的下一个国王，或者他是国王吗？当然拥有王冠。当然履行了国王的职责。他当然是奥利弗·克伦威尔。
for the top but the public sadly didn't agree um we did a podcast about him with Paul Ley. So we did a podcast on his terms law protector. Yes. And of course, the reason that we, you know, we said this in the preview, but the reason that we wanted Cromwell in and felt he deserved to be in wasn't just to generate clicks. It was because he filled a king-shaped gap in the Constitution that's been left by the execution of Charles I.
他是我的夺冠热门，但公众很遗憾并不这么认为。我们和保罗·莱（Paul Ley）一起做了一个关于他的播客。所以我们做了一期关于他担任护国公的播客。是的。当然，我们之所以，你知道的，我们在预告片里说过这个，但我们希望克伦威尔加入并且觉得他配得上加入，不仅仅是为了吸引点击量。而是因为他在宪法中填补了一个由查理一世被处决所留下的国王形状的空白。
But yes, so we have actually covered the protectorate in another episode so if you want to know more about that um we did that with paul lay author of a fabulous book on uh cromwell's protectorate uh do suggest that so i think and i think that we're going to look i mean we're going to come back we're doing an episode on the excuse on the trial and execution of charles i we are i will simply say i think cromwell was very hard done by in this tournament. I think he was an extremely effective ruler of England. He was feared abroad. He left the country on a sound footing. I just think he was a fine fellow.
但是，是的，所以我们实际上在另一集中讨论过护国公政体，如果你想了解更多关于这方面的信息，我们是和保罗·莱一起做的，他是关于克伦威尔护国公政体的一本极好的书的作者，我推荐那本书。所以我想，我认为我们要去看看，我的意思是，我们要回来，我们要制作一期关于查理一世审判和处决的播客。是的，我只想说，我认为克伦威尔在这个锦标赛中受到了很不公正的待遇。我认为他是英格兰一位极其高效的统治者。他在国外令人敬畏。他为国家奠定了稳固的基础。我只是觉得他是个很好的人。
I like Oliver Cromwell a lot. I know that some listeners absolutely find that absolutely despicable. He obviously, there are large numbers of people who feel very very passionately about him of whom people in Ireland are obviously absolutely at the top of that list
我非常喜欢奥利弗·克伦威尔。我知道有些听众绝对觉得这绝对令人鄙视。显然，有大量的人对他的看法非常非常强烈，其中爱尔兰人显然是名列榜首的。
but also royalists and a capital law for instance very cross about Cromwell's presence. Yeah, I would rather have a plain russeted captain that knows what he And a capolò, for instance. Very cross about Cromwell's presence. Yeah. I would rather have a plain russeted captain that knows what he fights for and loves what he knows than that which you call a gentleman and is nothing else. I beseech you in the bowels of Christ, think it possible,
但保王党和卡波洛（capolò）例如，对克伦威尔的出现非常生气。是的，我宁愿要一个朴素的、懂得为什么而战、热爱他所知道的东西的粗呢呢上尉，也不愿要你所说的那种除了是个绅士之外什么都不是的人。我祈求你们，以基督的怜悯，认为这是可能的，
you may be mistaken. See, I think I could have... I know I played Beckett, but I think Cromwell was the part I was born to play. I would love to go around, you know, ordering major generals to stamp out fun. I mean, that's my thing. Well, there's a vision.
你可能弄错了。你看，我觉得我可以……我知道我演过贝克特，但我认为克伦威尔是我生来就要扮演的角色。我很乐意四处走走，你知道的，命令少将们消灭娱乐。我的意思是，这就是我的风格。好吧，这是一个愿景。
So anyway, he lost, didn't he? Who did he lose to? He lost to Charles II. Charles II, of course, in that derby. Yeah, classic. I mean, he was never going to win. It was closer than I thought, actually, because Charles II, who was, of course, wrong but romantic again,
所以无论如何，他输了，不是吗？他输给了谁？他输给了查理二世。查理二世，当然，在这场德比中。是的，经典。我的意思是，他从来没打算赢。实际上，比我想象的要接近，因为查理二世，当然，又是错误但浪漫，
he was always going to prevail. So Charles II, I would have thought that he was the seed who was like least dropout. But I thought that Cromwell might beat him. Did you? Because I think Cromwell is such a titanic figure. I mean, much more of a titanic figure than Charles II. But obviously, though, Cromwell, for my money, is the single most interesting person in English history. I think that's entirely true. No, I think that's entirely true.
他总是会占上风。所以对于查理二世，我本以为他是那个最不可能被淘汰的种子选手。但我以为克伦威尔会击败他。是吗？因为我觉得克伦威尔是一个如此泰坦般的人物。我的意思是，比查理二世更具泰坦色彩。但显而易见的是，在我看来，克伦威尔是英国历史上最有趣的人物。我认为这完全正确。不，我认为这完全正确。
The most complex, the most controversial, therefore I think the most interesting. I mean, it doesn't make him the most admirable, but I think it makes him the most interesting. We should mention actually Ronald Hutton's absolutely, I mean some listeners will know that Ronald Hutton came on to talk about the history of paganism, but his most recent book is called The Making of Oliver Cromwell.
最复杂，最具争议性，因此我认为最有趣。我的意思是，这并不意味着他最值得钦佩，但我认为这使他最有趣。我们实际上应该提到罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）的绝对……我的意思是，一些听众会知道罗纳德·赫顿曾来谈论过异教的历史，但他最近的一本书叫做《奥利弗·克伦威尔的崛起》。
It's an absolutely fantastic. Yes, the first of a three-part biography of him. Yeah. Yeah, really fabulous. Locating him in the landscape and in the kind of the imaginative world of the 17th century. Just absolutely brilliant. But Cromwell, I had thought that if a seed was going to drop out, it was going to be Charles II. But interestingly, the seed that dropped out was Victoria. And she was up against athelstan who ultimately of course
这是一本绝对棒极了的书。是的，关于他的三部传记的第一部。是的，真的非常棒。把他放在17th世纪的风景和想象世界中。简直棒极了。但是克伦威尔，我曾以为如果有哪一颗种子会被淘汰，那将是查理二世。但有趣的是，被淘汰的种子是维多利亚。她对阵的是埃塞尔斯坦，后者最终当然
won uh victoria were you surprised victoria lost so victoria was the number five no i suppose i wasn't well i mean was that you said beforehand that you thought that series that's on tv with jenna coleman playing the young victorian which is very kind of romantic giddy figure would would endear her to the public. But I think Victoria suffers from two things. One is the sort of, she never has escaped the sort of post-death of Prince Albert. Yeah, the widow of Windsor.
赢了。维多利亚，你对维多利亚输了感到惊讶吗？所以维多利亚是五号种子，不，我想我并不惊讶。好吧，我的意思是，你之前说过你认为电视上由珍娜·科尔曼扮演年轻维多利亚的那部剧，那种非常浪漫、头晕目眩的人物形象，会让她赢得公众的喜爱。但我认为维多利亚受到了两件事的困扰。一个是那种，她从来没有摆脱过阿尔伯特亲王去世后的那种状态。是的，温莎寡妇。
The widow, exactly. The sort of, we are not amused, humourless, that sort of image of her, which is of course a bit of a caricature, but has become absolutely, you know, it's embedded in our national imagination. And I think the other thing is the one thing that people would once always have held up and said, hurrah, hurrah for Victoria. Britain was at its zenith, the empire, she was Empress of India. You know,
寡妇，完全没错。那种“我们很不高兴”、缺乏幽默感、她的那种形象，这当然有点夸张，但已经绝对，你知道的，它已经根植于我们的国家想象中。我认为另一件事是，人们曾经总是会举起并说：为维多利亚欢呼，为维多利亚欢呼。英国正处于鼎盛时期，帝国，她是印度女皇。你知道，
she's a figurehead of greatness. That's now, you know, a lot of people don't sign up to that anymore. So in other words, she's lost a bit of her natural constituency. Yes, I think that's true. I think that's true. And also, of course, I mean, this is something we'll probably talk about in tomorrow's episode, is that all the kings and law protectors that we've discussed so far were very powerful agents in their own right. Yeah. We also have George V and Elizabeth II who were constitutional monarchs. Victoria is the kind of intersection point because she effectively, the power of the monarchy is ebbing away. But she still tries, doesn't she?
她是伟大的化身。现在，你知道的，很多人不再认同这一点了。换句话说，她失去了一部分天然选民。是的，我认为这很对。我认为这确实如此。而且，当然，我的意思是，这是我们明天节目中可能会谈论的事情，那就是我们迄今为止讨论的所有国王和护国公都是他们自己权利下的强大推动者。是的。我们还有乔治五世和伊丽莎白二世，他们是立宪君主。维多利亚是那种交叉点，因为她实际上，君主的权力正在消退。但她仍然在尝试，不是吗？
There's a very famous moment in 1839 when Lord Melbourne, who was her first prime minister, who she adored, he resigned. And his replacement, I think, was going to be Peel. And he wants to change the ladies of the bedchamber who always change when the administration, when the ministry changes. But she won't have it. So Melbourne comes back in and then soldiers on for another two years to 1841. And that's one of the last moments when a monarch genuinely changes the course of political history. But that's the last gasp against the tide. Yeah, exactly. And I think, certainly, she hated Gladstone,
1839年有一个非常著名的时刻，墨尔本勋爵，他是她的第一任首相，她非常崇拜他，他辞职了。他的接替者，我想将是皮尔。他想更换寝室女官，每当政府更迭、内阁更迭时，寝室女官总是会更换。但她不肯。所以墨尔本又回来了，然后坚持了两年，直到1841年。这是君主真正改变政治历史进程的最后时刻之一。但那是逆潮而动的最后挣扎。是的，完全正确。而且我认为，毫无疑问，她讨厌格莱斯顿，
another friend of the show. Loved Israeli. Loved Israeli. But Gladstone keeps winning elections, so there's nothing she can do about it. And she has to put up with him and she complains, oh, he speaks to me as though I'm a public meeting and they have this terrible, frosty relationship.
节目的另一个朋友。喜欢迪斯雷利。喜欢迪斯雷利。但格莱斯顿不断赢得选举，所以她对此无可奈何。她不得不忍受他，她抱怨说，“哦，他对我说话的样子就像我在参加一个公众集会”，他们有着这种糟糕的、冷淡的关系。
But she is powerless. Certainly by the end of her reign, she's almost completely powerless. But I think it scrambles the measures by which you're judging her. So, you know, Henry II or whoever, Cromwell even, these are actors and you're judging them by what they achieved in their own right. Elizabeth II, I mean, she does well because she's the kind of model of what a constitutional monarch should be. But Victoria, more ambivalent, I think.
但她是无能为力的。当然，到她统治末期，她几乎完全无能为力。但我认为这打乱了你评判她的标准。所以，你知道的，亨利二世或任何人，甚至是克伦威尔，这些都是行动者，你是根据他们凭自身能力取得的成就来评判他们的。伊丽莎白二世，我的意思是，她表现得很好，因为她是立宪君主应该成为的榜样。但维多利亚则更加矛盾，我认为。
Well, she survived a lot of attempts to assassinate her. She survived a great upsurge of Republican feeling in the sort of middle to later part of her reign. The one thing she did do, though, Tom, was to almost in some ways invent the modern monarchy yeah she invents the idea of the the idea she married albert doesn't she and both of them have come from very unhappy kind of broken backgrounds and they create this model of domesticity exactly that becomes hugely hugely she becomes a middle-class queen exactly as
嗯，她挺过了很多次刺杀她的企图。她挺过了在她统治的中后期出现的一波巨大的共和主义情绪。然而，她确实做的一件事，汤姆，就是几乎在某种程度上发明的现代君主制。是的，她发明了这种理念，她嫁给阿尔伯特，不是吗？他们俩都来自非常不幸的、破碎的背景，他们创造了这种家庭主义的模式，正如
historians have said you know it's the blend of the domestic and the spectacular, the ordinary and the extraordinary, that becomes the sort of, as it were, the magic, the formula, I guess, of the British monarchy. And she creates that formula and is actually, when you look back, despite the fact that she was often controversial and indeed unpopular, she's very successful at a time when other monarchies are crumbling, at putting that at the centre of British kind of political culture. And I think that, I mean, I think she's a complex character, isn't she?
历史学家所说，正是家庭与壮丽、平凡与非凡的结合，成为了英国君主制的某种魔力，或者说公式。她创造了这个公式，并且实际上，当你回首往事时，尽管她经常充满争议甚至不受欢迎，但当其他君主国正在崩塌的时候，她非常成功地将这一点置于英国政治文化的核心。而且我认为，我的意思是，我认为她是一个复杂的人物，不是吗？
She's full of contradictions. She is. I mean, she's very passionate. Yes, very passionate. She's not, you know, this idea of her as a sort of humorless, withdrawn figure. I mean, obviously, when she's grieving after Prince Albert, you can understand that. But for a lot of the time, she's actually a very impulsive character. Well, there are a lot of jokes made about that, aren't there?
她充满了矛盾。她的确如此。我的意思是，她非常有激情。是的，非常有激情。她不是，你知道的，这种把她视为缺乏幽默感、孤僻人物的看法。我的意思是，当然，当她在阿尔伯特亲王去世后悲痛时，你可以理解这一点。但很多时候，她实际上是一个非常冲动的角色。嗯，有很多关于这方面的笑话，不是吗？
So she's very, very keen on Lord Melbourne. And so people barrack her and shout out Lady Melbourne at her when they cross with her. And then there's all the stuff about after Albert's died and she's kind of grieving with with uh john brown and then later on there's an indian servant called the munchie yeah so she has a series of crushes on people i think it's probably fair so i mean yeah i think i mean i think she's she's obviously such an important figure such a fascinating figure that we should do uh we absolutely do an entire episode on it's ridiculous to try and sum her up in now talking a fascinating figure that we should do an entire episode on. It's ridiculous to try and sum her up in five minutes. Now, talking of fascinating figures.
所以她非常非常喜欢墨尔本勋爵。因此，当人们对她生气时，会起哄并向她大喊“墨尔本夫人”。然后还有阿尔伯特死后她和约翰·布朗一起悲伤的事情，后来还有一个叫孟吉的印度仆人。是的，她对一些人有一连串的迷恋，我觉得这样说大概很公平。所以，我的意思是，是的，我认为，我的意思是，她显然是一个如此重要的人物，一个如此迷人的人物，以至于我们应该制作，我们绝对应该制作一整集关于她的节目，试图在现在谈论一个迷人的人物时在五分钟内总结她，这是荒谬的。我们应该制作一整集。
Yes. So the final match. Here's my favourite, one of my absolute favourite historical figures. So the final match featured Henry VIII, a man of gargantuan appetites who killed his wives, who basically did whatever he wanted to. Probably the most famous, not just English king, but most famous king who's ever lived. And who is he up against, Dominic?
是的。所以最后的决赛。这是我最喜欢的，我绝对最喜欢的历史人物之一。所以最后的决赛由亨利八世对阵，一个胃口巨大、杀死妻子、基本上为所欲为的男人。可能不仅是英国国王中最著名的，而且是有史以来最著名的国王。他面对的对手是谁，多米尼克？
He was up against another titanic figure in George V. I love George V, but it is fair to say that George V is possibly one of the most boring men who's ever walked the earth. So George V was the second son. His older brother was called Albert Victor. v was the second son his older brother was called albert victor he was the second son of edward the seventh so he's victoria's grandson he becomes king in 1910 because his brother had died a little bit earlier leaving him as the heir he has a tattoo of a dragon um he's a very naval character so he's got a tattoo and that's why he that's why and we have we had there's a wonderful tweet from andrew harrison
他面对的是另一个泰坦式的人物——乔治五世。我喜欢乔治五世，但公平地说，乔治五世可能是世界上最无聊的男人之一。所以乔治五世是第二个儿子。他的哥哥叫阿尔伯特·维克托。五世是第二个儿子，他的哥哥叫阿尔伯特·维克托。他是爱德华七世的第二个儿子，所以他是维多利亚的孙子。他在1910年成为国王，因为他的哥哥早些时候去世了，留下了他作为继承人。他有一条龙的纹身，嗯，他是一个非常具有海军风范的人，所以他有纹身，这就是为什么他，这就是为什么，我们有，安德鲁·哈里森有一条精彩的推文，
um who listened to a podcast on george v which failed to mention the key issues of trouser creases and the kaiser's deck shoes sadly lacking in top punditry will stick to the rest of history quite right yeah so he creases his trousers in the naval fashion doesn't he yes at the sides rather than which you've mentioned several times, and he does wear the right deck shoes. Unlike his cousin. The Kaiser. The Kaiser. So he also looks identical to the Tsar of Russia.
他听了一个关于乔治五世的播客，其中没有提到裤线和德皇的甲板鞋的关键问题，遗憾的是缺乏顶级专家水平的评论。我们还是坚持听《历史就是所以他像海军那样给裤子折出折痕，不是吗？是的，在两侧，而不是像你提到过好几次的那样，而且他确实穿了正确的甲板鞋。不像他的堂兄。德皇。德皇。所以他长得也跟俄国沙皇一模一样。
So there are all these sort of pictures of him and the Tsar smiling happily together. Little do they know what is coming. Well, and notoriously, when the Russian Revolution happens and there's talk about giving sanctuary to the Tsar and the Tsarina, he says no because this might rock the foundations of the British monarchy. Yeah, because Lord Stamfordham and some of his advisors say it will stir republicanism and sort of socialist agitation in Britain if you invite your relatives over.
所以有所有这些他跟沙皇开心地微笑着的照片。他们一点也不知道接下来会发生什么。嗯，众所周知，当俄国革命发生，有谈论要给沙皇和沙皇皇后提供庇护时，他说不，因为这可能会动摇英国君主制的基石。是的，因为斯坦福姆勋爵和他的一些顾问说，如果你把你的亲戚请过来，会在英国激起共和主义和某种社会主义煽动。
So he doesn't. And he feels guilty about that. Tom Hollander played him on TV in a brilliant thing called, I think, The Lost Prince by Stephen Poliakoff. And it's an amazingly moving scene when he finds out that his relatives have all been murdered, which has always led me to think well of George V. Now, Harold Nicholson said of him, for 17 years before his accession, he did nothing at all but kill animals and stick in stamps. Is that fair? That is fair, actually. I was reading a thing this morning about how he killed 1,000 pheasants in a day
所以他没有这么做。他为此感到内疚。汤姆·霍兰德在一个名为《失落的王子》（由斯蒂芬·波利亚科夫执导）的精彩节目中在电视上扮演了他。当他发现自己的亲戚都被谋杀时，这是一个非常感人的场景，这总是让我对乔治五世产生好感。现在，哈罗德·尼科尔森对他的评价是：在他登基前的17年里，他什么也没做，只是杀动物和贴邮票。这公平吗？这其实挺公平的。我今天早上读到一篇文章，讲他如何在一天之内杀死了1000只野鸡，
and afterwards wrote in his diary something. I feel we may have gone a little bit too far. So he was a great fan of hunting, country sports, countrymen, a great philatelist. So the world's greatest philatelist, some people might say. Yes. The world's greatest stamp collector. Wasn't there some courtier who said, I've just read in the paper that some damn fool has paid £4,000 for some damn fool's stamp.
事后在日记里写了些什么。我觉得我们可能有点做得过头了。所以他是打猎、乡村运动、乡村居民的超级粉丝，也是一个伟大的集邮家。所以有人可能会说，他是世界最伟大的集邮家。是的。世界最伟大的集邮收藏家。难道没有某个朝臣说过：“我刚在报纸上看到某个大傻瓜花4000英镑买了一个大傻瓜的邮票吗？”
Yeah, that's right. And George V said, well, the damn fool is me. Yes, that's absolutely right. Yeah. And he was a real stickler for the formalities. So people, if they wore the wrong shoes at court, you would have been in terrible trouble. Because if you wore the wrong shoes, you weren't invited. You weren't invited.
是的，没错。乔治五世说：“嗯，那个大傻瓜就是我。”是的，完全正确。是的。他是个真正的形式主义狂热分子。所以人们，如果他们在宫廷里穿错了鞋子，你就会遇到大麻烦。因为如果你穿错了鞋子，你根本不会被邀请。你不会被邀请的。
So hence the First World War. Yeah. Yeah, you weren't invited. So hence the First World War. Yeah. Yeah, you weren't invited. Deck shoe carnage. But the great thing about George V, actually, he's, again, in an incredibly unstable period. He is a beacon. He is a bulwark of stability.
因此第一次世界大战就爆发了。是的。是的，你没有被邀请。因此第一次世界大战就爆发了。是的。是的，你没有被邀请。甲板鞋大屠杀。但乔治五世的伟大之处在于，在极其不稳定的时期，他是一个灯塔。他是稳定的中流砥柱。
So this is why you and Tracy Borman, between you both nominated. I didn't. Yeah. I thought it was ridiculous. This is a point at which he the monarchy could easily have been blown away but also tom he does a couple of things that are very important um he urges conciliation and moderation during the irish war of independence in the early
这就是为什么你和特蕾西·博尔曼（Tracy Borman）你们俩共同提名了。我没有。是的。我觉得太荒谬了。这是一个君主制很容易被摧毁的时刻，但汤姆，他也做了几件非常重要的事情，在早期爱尔兰独立战争期间，他敦促调解和温和。
1920s so he is horrified by the fighting in ireland and that's why um he he he stops lloyd george from calling a battle no churchill perhaps, a battleship, the Oliver Cromwell. Exactly, all these kind of things. So there's that. There is, during the general strike, again, he urges moderation. So he says to, I don't know if this is apocryphal, but he's said to have said to some Tory ministers or something about the striking miners and so on,
19世纪20年代，所以他对爱尔兰的战斗感到惊恐，这就是为什么他阻止劳合·乔治称一艘战列舰为“奥利弗·克伦威尔”号，也许是丘吉尔？没错，所有这些事情。所以有这个。在总罢工期间，他再次敦促温和。所以他对，我不知道这是否是杜撰的，但他据说是对一些托利党大臣或其他人说了关于罢工矿工之类的话，
try living on their wages before you judge them. So if you did say that's very good for him in 1931 he creates in them as the great depression is hitting he basically creates a national government of some ramsay mcdonald the lady gets on well with labor doesn't he doesn't exceed any well with labor so when the first labor government comes in i mean this has always been the case labor leaders always seem to get on well with mollusks yeah it's pretty it's pretty true actually so he gets an exceedingly well with the first labor government um they have a guy called uh what's his name jimmy jimmy i can't remember what his name i can't remember anyway um he's a
在评判他们之前，先试着靠他们的工资生活。如果你真的说过这话，那对他在1931年的表现来说太棒了，当时大萧条正在袭来，他基本上建立了一个由拉姆齐·麦克唐纳领导的联合政府。这位女士与工党相处得很好，不是吗？他与工党相处得很好。所以当第一届工党政府上台时——这总是这样——工党领袖似乎总是与软体动物相处得很好。是的，这其实挺准确的。所以他与第一届工党政府相处得极其融洽，他们有一个叫什么名字的家伙，吉米，吉米，我想不起来他叫什么名字了，我想不起来了，无论如何，他是一个
um former railwayman and he gets on absolutely tremendously with george v and they tell dirty jokes to each other and have an absolute whale of a time so he's very good at bringing labor into the kind of into the sort of political mainstream if you like uh what's edward the eighth who is his son so he had a dreadful son obviously he'd be a lead contender for the worst worst king edward the eighth that feckless feckless nazi yes well i mean yeah i'm not going to make the i'm not going to make the inevitable analogy with a current member of the Royal Family. But anyway, Edward VIII was that man. So he'd currently be in California.
前铁路工人，他与乔治五世相处得绝对融洽，他们互相讲荤段子，玩得不亦乐乎。所以他非常擅长把工党拉入政治主流，如果你愿意这么说的话。爱德华八世是谁？他是他的儿子。所以他有一个糟糕的儿子，显然他将是最糟糕国王爱德华八世的有力争夺者，那个毫无责任心的纳粹分子。是的，好吧，我的意思是，我不会做，我不会与王室的现任成员做不可避免的类比。但无论如何，爱德华八世就是那个人。所以他目前会在加利福尼亚。
And he said of his father, his beliefs were God, the invincibility of the Royal Navy, and the essential rightness of whatever was British. I mean, you'd think that would be enough to get him to the later rounds of the competition, wouldn't you, Tom? What's gone wrong? What's gone wrong? Oh, and also he changed the family name to Windsor, didn't he? He did, of course. Prompting the family name to Windsor didn't he he did of course
他评价他的父亲说：他的信仰是上帝、皇家海军的不可战胜性，以及凡是英国的事物的本质正确性。我的意思是，你会觉得这足以让他进入比赛的后期阶段，对吧，汤姆？哪里出问题了？哪里出问题了？哦，他还把家族姓氏改成了温莎，不是吗？他当然这么做了。促使
prompting the Kaiser's famous joke and of course he dies so there are can I just say the Kaiser's famous joke go on then oh yeah go on go on
德皇开了一个著名的玩笑，当然他快死了，所以有——我能讲一下德皇著名的玩笑吗？那就讲吧，哦，好的，讲吧，讲吧。
I know what you're going to say he was off to see the merry wives of Saxe-Coburg very good basically the Kaiser's only joke I think isn't it
我知道你要说什么，他去看萨克森-科堡的快乐妻子们了。非常棒，基本上是德皇唯一的笑话，我想，对吧？
yes probably so he dies in he has he spent time recuperating in Bognor, hadn't he? Yeah. So hence Bognor Regis. Bognor Regis.
是的，大概是这样。所以他在那里去世，他曾在博格纳疗养过，不是吗？是的。所以因此有了博格纳雷吉斯。博格纳雷吉斯。
So before that, in 1935, he had a tremendous jubilee. Very successful. And he said, I can't understand it. After all, I'm only a very ordinary sort of fellow. That's so soundproof. That's a nice thing to say. That's so soundproof. He'd done the first royal broadcast as well, didn't he?
在此之前，在1935年，他举行了一个盛大的禧年。非常成功。他说：“我无法理解。毕竟，我只是一个非常普通的家伙。”这太无懈可击了。这是一个很好的说法。这太无懈可击了。他也做过第一次皇家广播，不是吗？
See, that's what I say about the success of the rest is history. Yeah, so he changed the name to Windsor. He established the Royal Broadcast. He established the idea of being boring is a good thing. Yeah, exactly. He established the template for the 20th century. And then he dies in 1936. He's dying.
看，这就是我对《历史就是一切》成功的评价。是的，所以他把名字改成了温莎。他创立了皇家广播。他确立了“无聊是一件好事”的理念。是的，完全正确。他为20世纪确立了模板。然后他在1936年去世了。他正在垂死。
And his doctor famously administers a fatal dose basically to kill him off and to get him in the times right so that it will be reported in the times rather than the the more down market evening papers um and so there are three different accounts of what he said one one is that somebody said to him you'll be right as rain soon you can go back to to Bogner Regis. And he said, bugger Bogner. The official thing that he was meant to have said was, how is the empire? Somebody said, it's great. And he said, he smiled and died.
他的医生以臭名昭著的手段给他注射了致死剂量的药物，基本上是为了除掉他，让他能登上《泰晤士报》的头条，这样就能在《泰晤士报》上报道，而不是在那些更低端的晚报上。所以关于他的遗言有三种不同的说法：一种是有人对他说：“你很快就会像雨后春笋一样恢复健康的，你可以回博格纳雷吉斯了。”他说：“见鬼去吧，博格纳。”官方宣称他本该说的话是：“帝国怎么样？”有人说：“好得很。”他说，他微笑着死去了。
But apparently one of the doctors wrote in his diary that actually the last thing he said was a nurse gave him a sedative or something. And he just said, God damn you. That sounds more more probable it definitely sounds more probable yes so he bowed out i think very unfairly um because i'm the eighth i mean well i wanted him to be henry yeah of course so they were the um they were the first fallers now tom holland has to go off right now um to talk to the nation about to address the nation about athelstan the winner um on the
但显然其中一个医生在他的日记里写道，实际上他说的最后的话是一个护士给他用了镇静剂什么的。他只是说：“天打雷劈你。”听起来更合理。这绝对听起来更合理，是的。所以他非常不公平地被淘汰了，因为第八爱德华——我的意思是，我希望他是亨利，是的，当然。所以他们是第一批出局的人。现在汤姆·霍兰德必须马上去，向全国发表讲话，向全国发表关于最终胜者埃塞尔斯坦的讲话，
on the bbc so we will bring this podcast to a close but coming up yes we've got we've got the the quarterfinals so we've got elizabeth the second against henry the fifth we've got william the first against henry the eighth we've got elizabeth first against charles the second we've got athelstan against edward the third uh so we've got um we've got lots and lots more to talk about. And we'll talk about the changing nature of kingship as well. That's very exciting. So we'll be doing all that tomorrow. Stay tuned.
在BBC上。所以我们要结束这期播客了。但是接下来，是的，我们有四分之一决赛，伊丽莎白二世对阵亨利五世，威廉一世对阵亨利八世，伊丽莎白一世对阵查理二世，埃塞尔斯坦对阵爱德华三世。所以我们有很多很多的话题要聊。我们也会谈到君主制性质的变化。这非常令人兴奋。所以我们明天会做所有这些。敬请收听。
And we will see you then. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们到时见。再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史就是一切》。想要收听额外单集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。